Speaker 1: We're taking calls via Discord
David Pakman dot com slash discord is the
place to go and the way that you can talk
to me.
Let's go next to Angel from New York, Angel.
You're on the air.
Angel from New York, welcome, you're on the
air.
Speaker 2: I'm sorry about that, I was muted.
Now you're on muted.
Our good at my question for you, I mean, I
work for
Speaker 7: a public sector trade union, a
fairly powerful one at that.
My question to you is why do so many people
in these trade unions?
I'm not talking about teachers or police,
since it's fair way fairly obvious where they
fall politically and why they do.
What do other people, firefighters, steelworkers?
Why do they seem to lean to the right, not
just on cultural issues, but even economic
ones?
And what can the left do about that?
Because it seems like an unwinnable battle?
Speaker 1: So I take issue with one aspect
of what you're saying.
I think you are 100 percent correct that a
lot of the kind of labor or trade union members
have absolutely moved to the right in terms
of how they vote over the last 20 years.
And I think that the part where you're wrong
is if you really sit down and talk to these
folks about economic issues, they're they're
very clearly on the left.
The problem is that the cultural conservatism
of some of those unions combined with people
who just are busy living their lives and aren't
really thinking through the economic issues
and the proposals of candidates are just kind
of saying, Yeah, I believe I'm a Republican.
But when you really talk to them about economic
issues, the things they tell you line up with
what Democrats are mostly proposing and not
with Republicans.
So it's unfortunate because they're still
voting for Republicans, but I don't actually
think that they have moved to the right economically.
I think they just think they have and they're
part of these culturally conservative environment.
And so they just go, I'm a Republican, I'm
voting for Republicans.
But if you really sat him down, you'd see
that they really aligned with Democrats on
economic issues.
Speaker 7: Yeah, I suppose you're right.
I it's more of a signaling thing like, I,
you know, I've got family members, I know
friends, these people, the don't work for
a public sector trade union, which even we
have reservations about collective bargaining
against the taxpayer.
But you know, like one guy will have a like
the Gadsden flag.
Don't tread on me.
Yep.
At the very least, they'll signal they'll
they'll signal issues with high taxes or gas
prices.
So I do think that if you if you sat them
down and really tried to get at how they feel
about things, they're definitely to the left.
And then I guess what I'm seeing it economically
is still it still could be grouped under under
a cultural understanding of where they were.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, with a lot of these
folks, if you say, what do you see as wrong
with the economy, how would you fix it?
You're going to get a discourse that points
to Democrats, not to Republicans.
The problem is they still there's a lot of
them still vote for Republicans, and that's
sad.
But when you really talk to them, you would
see that they point left.
Speaker 7: Yeah.
So what do what do Democrats do about that?
Speaker 1: I don't know.
I mean, it's again, it's a messaging failure.
I don't know the answer.
If I knew the answer, I'd be a political political
consultant, but I don't know.
It's just an area Democrats continue to fail
on.
Speaker 7: Hmm.
All right.
Speaker 1: Well, thanks for talking to me.
Appreciate the call.
Yeah, I wish I had something a little more.
I guess optimistic to say that's going to
do it.
That's going to.
Thank you so much, Angel from from New York.
Appreciate it.
That's going to do it for calls today.
I, as always, was unable to get to every caller,
but I'm going to try to get to more callers
when we take calls again.
We'll take a quick break and be right back
with
more show.